j'ai une aide qui s'appelle les troupes
tenez marie maison oui c'est exactement
ce que tu dois dit bon alors on fait
comme si on était les autres salles et
harry salut tu veux jouer à cache cache
avec nous oui joie qu'il soit bon
jusqu'à 10 et nous pendant ce temps là
on veut se cacher bah non non pas papa
moi je suis le gentil copains qui veut
jouer avec toi d'accord et ak non contre
jusqu'à 10
je suis là
r c'est un truc de valeur je suis
vraiment manage ils pourront voir des
vieux ça on voit des commandes a trop
chaud
mais si tu veux chez rhdp soit sympa
installe toi plutôt à l'arrière penche
toi et c'est le but et loi partie à la
recherche de mes parents odiah terme de
la tente où la bad moraux auxquels il ya
pas longtemps que la mémoire est revenu
alors je suis pas très sûr mais quelque
chose me dit que doivent être plutôt
bleu avec une boîte de janvier des
chances
oui je suis sûr que je les reconnaîtrais
des clés vers l air de famille
moi je dis que la traversée de l'océan
c'est le genre de croisière qu'il faut
avoir fait une fois dans sa vie
seuls les copains prochaine sortie la
faille de bon
si c'est toi qui la girouette
vous savez bonjour je m'appelle de riz
je sais donc de quoi comme le dit moi je
suis pas mal et on mise en quarantaine
au nom il reste combien de temps à vivre
il faut qu'aujourd'hui les parents à
l'arête aux courbes ou au non c'est pas
bon choix
qu'est-ce qu'il ya qu'est ce qui se
passe est une très mauvaise nouvelle
c'est une étiquette de transport pour
les poissons qu'on aucune chance à
l'institut on les transfère dans un lieu
de vie définitive un aquarium
ma famille et je n'ai pas peur
et ce sont là quelques pas et donc je
les retrouve on mettrait la trouver
où étiez-vous c'est toi qui a disparu
mes parents je me rappelle ça y est quoi
qu'est ce que tu te rappelles je me
souviens de mes parents ma mère mon père
j'ai une famille et le satan je suis
d'origine non non c'est la folie où tu
veux aller d'abord mao au diamant de
l'avs
bâti au lieu de l'avesnois californie
ces salons dorés la californie c'est de
l'autre côté de l'océan leur faut y
aller mais enfin pourquoi chaque fois
qu'on est on porte un récif il faut
qu'il y en ait un qui prennent le large
on ne pourrait pas se contenter de jouir
de la vue qui me parle de la vue alors
que j'y viens de te dire que je me
souvienne les parois non les grands
voyages s'est terminée il ya un temps
pour tout dans la vie
j'ai déjà voyagé je sais de quoi je
parle le meilleur moment dans le voyage
c'est quand on rentre à la maison
dans nuirait de parler moins fort j'ai
mal à la tête qui s simon france un pays
là il est arrivé que de blessures hawks
je sais que tu parle de moi d'espérer
qu'il peut plus servir de son sonar mais
j'ai entendu les mythes 118 absolument
tout ce que tu dis sur moi c'est quoi un
sonar normalement la tête de bellême et
des ultrasons et l'écholocalisation lui
permet de repérer des objets à distance
mais apparemment monsieur n'est pas
encore guéri ok donc là c'est sûr tu
parles demain je réellement perdu
l'écholocalisation vue c'est toujours la
même accusation
je me suis violemment cognée la tête
parce que ça c'est pas une bosse
peut-être c'est tout à fait normal pour
un béluga d'avoir une grosse tête
attendre non non non non je sais où sont
mes parents ils sont dans la c'est quoi
la bassine dans le garage mais sans
grand large le baça grand large le
bassin grand large
je sais où ça c'est le grand bassin qui
est juste à côté de débrouille toi tout
seul et arrêtent un le mieux pour
rejoindre le bassin grand large c'est
par les tuyaux par les tuyaux
voilà par les tuyaux oui rend deux fois
à gauche et ensuite c'est tout droit à
ça alors c'est compliqué à retenir donc
tu entendu tu te souviens oui formidable
amis si je peux pas bien avec toi je
suis trop gros vas-y tout seul c'est que
c'est à dire je peux pas je suis pages
j'ai pas trop le sens de l'orientation
c'est dommage mais ce qui est convenu
est convenu tu veux retrouver tes
parents c'est par là donne-moi
l'étiquette je peux pas y aller tout
seul je serai plus j'ai pas mon problème
d'éthique est